you know someone that died tragically in
a car accident or a guys I'm Theresa
Caputo the Long Island medium and I am
here on the BuzzFeed on the BuzzFeed I'm
Eric Tuvok I work for BuzzFeed and I'm
gonna get my I'm gonna contact the dead
as you are I don't know or you're gonna
contact the dead for me how does this
work can you talk a little bit about
like yeah sure so I I have an amazing
beautiful gift I have the ability to
sense and feel the soul so that's
supported and more importantly I've been
blessed to share my gift on TLC for the
past eight years I've watched a bunch of
episodes and yeah that's why I'm like
stressed because I feel like some of
them are very intense like we also saw
an episode where the sound guy or the
camera guy got run instead yeah that
happens that happens everyone has lost
someone that's the bottom line right but
not everyone wants or more importantly
needs to hear from their departed loved
ones when I first learned about my gift
cuz on the first one say that what I do
is absolutely crazy I couldn't
understand why someone would even want
to come and see me yeah but what I
learned is that unfortunately when we
lose someone young or old we here in the
physical world are left with all of
these negative emotions and burdens
maybe I should have could have would
have been an only if and all of these
emotions don't give us the ability to
heal so what I do is about healing
you have amazing energy by the way yeah
you're so beautiful like I just I feel
like it's so beautiful but when I see
someone I see like their soul you know I
like see really like what's inside you
know and I just I feel like you're so
talented and so yeah very very beautiful
soul I always just say whatever I see or
feel and I've never seen this before so
this even makes it even more amazing
would you remember years ago used to
take sidewalk chalk and make like a
hopscotch what is that like I don't have
a meaning for that so usually when when
if I'm gonna kill you no spirit wants to
communicate they show me things like
that but I think it interesting about
this this drawing of the sidewalk hook
so I don't know what it is
did who's the young
so that's departed yeah you know someone
that died tragically in a car accident
or C so I cuz I founded it you mean why
are you bringing me back to like this
childhood you you understand that so
usually when spirit shows me like a um a
car accident and they like switch seats
with me
that's my symbol for with someone but
they carry a survivor's guilt and what I
mean by that is oh my god I was supposed
to be with them this never would have
happened or I was supposed to pick them
up whatever it is or there was a
switching implants it validates that
they do not want us to feel guilty or
bad because we survived and we're still
here and they departed especially in
this tragedy so was there a something
about the seatbelt because usually when
spirit shows me a mark on a seatbelt
music they want to make reference to
whether it could have been they weren't
wearing it or they were wearing it and
it was the mark from the seatbelt well
I'm not sure if he wasn't wearing a
seatbelt or not he was on his way to a
church retreat and I'm not sure I think
he was driving but I'm not sure but
there had to be something about where
the plans were switched maybe he took a
different car maybe he wasn't supposed
to be driving whatever it is because
remember when he showed me the switching
of the seats with the survivor's guilt
I said to you I kind of felt like it
wasn't directly for you that would be
for someone else
did you have to open yourself up to
feeling something or it started to sound
it just started you have to one said I
was born this way so for me I don't I've
always sensed and felt things what I had
to understand was what spirit was trying
to communicate so that's why it's
important when I share my signs and
symbols where I could have a different
meaning for someone else so but you'll
have to tune in and watch the new season
of Long Island medium on Friday nights
that's super exciting I'm excited I
check it out thank you so much for
coming in and everything was such a
pleasure
how does she know that like it was weird
when she said car accident it just hit
me like I froze like she hit it right on
the nose and for me it just like hit me
like a ton of bricks like she knew
exactly who I would have wanted to talk
to and that that was just so weird it
was so bizarre I don't I don't have
words for it it didn't hit me really
until I talked with my family and they
were like ya know he wasn't supposed to
be in that car and I was just like okay
so she definitely spoke to my cousin
hello hey hi how are you he wasn't
wearing a seat belt yo oh my god I
didn't I didn't know that you know mommy
felt guilty just about just how
everything happened of just like she was
like you know we weren't that close and
after we moved and stuff and she felt
guilty of not being around as much or
like you know being together with the
family as much and stuff with him and he
was like or at least the medium said
that like any guilt that you're feeling
and I don't know if it's applies to you
too but any guilt that you're feeling of
anything let it go like he's happy and
he's in a good place
[Music]
I'm so happy that I was able to even
relay this message so I love you too
all right bye I mean that was a really
dark time for the entire family but I'm
just like I'm so thankful that somehow I
don't the stars aligned at the whatever
the universe made this happen somehow I
ended up by BuzzFeed and somehow I ended
up meeting the medium and I'd like my
family got closure which is that's
amazing
not everybody can say that
[Music]